[Music]
why do people i know you get criticism
online and you have people that tell you
that you're lying about your story
who are those people and why is that
happening
so i'm very hated by marxist maoists
leninist socialist communists right
because
north korea is the last country in this
earth right now horses ideological
socialism they themselves describe
themselves as a socialist paradise
north korea's name is not nurses dprk
democratic people's
republic of korea it's democratic you
know so it's socially they do they vote
they people vote but they got only one
guy to vote for
like north korea holds their elections
every five years is not a dictatorship
technically because they have elections
but when you go vote there's only one
person you should vote why
even bother because of socialism it's a
socialist paradise like that states say
why they have to
say i'm elected by the people therefore
like this is the last country
holds this ideology and what happens is
that the people anti-america
anti-freedom capitalism
hates like america and they know that
norway's enemy of them
so they hate me for me supporting free
market
capitalism democracy free speech and
also people
like i also made mistakes sometimes like
when i was
giving speeches i taught myself english
when i was like 21
and i did not know the difference
between here and mountain
so technically they say it's supposed to
be here i i climbed it three years but i
thought it was mountain how the
heck i know the what are to do do you
differentiate it and when i was
translating words to
like korean words to english words it
was grass
but turns out what i ate was plants so
there were like few things that i made a
mistake like
oh so that's what they go after as if
they know more than one language
yeah right so like i said why why are
you saying grass is a plant
so you're lying so you climb like i saw
the google earth and it's supposed to be
here it's not a mountain
but like i was 13 years old i had no
google earth how do i know it was like
that is like what their problem is but
the mainly is like
also i'm on the target list of kim
jong-un i mean he of course
tried because i spoke about my
regeneration of my
my family that i left behind in north
korea or been persecuted
they have denounced me and they've been
executed or sent to prison camp i have
no clue
so you know north korea has a lot of
hackers and the
these armies of hackers to try to
character assassinate people
i mean who like criticize the regime so
a lot of people do not like me
are you concerned about your safety oh
yeah i mean i get informed about
intelligence all the time like oh my god
you ain't throw like
you scare me a lot like you know the
intelligence calls you and say like stop
it
intelligence from where south korea
because i used to live in south korea
well i mean that was scary you know but
yeah
you know i could have been dead so many
times and
almost like this is like a second life
that was given to me and
i'm not going to live in fear again you
know i was the first thing my mom told
me when i was child when i was born in
north korea that
don't even whisper because the birds and
mice could hear me
i was so afraid even to think and now i
mean that is not
why i risked my life and going through
all of this to be free
if i get killed like you know kim jong
kid is a hot brother in malaysia a few
years ago
so if he wants to kill me nothing gonna
stop it
no i'm like against the most brutal
dictator in the world it's not up to me
to live or not i just do my best to
speak my truth until whenever that is
gonna be